so these are times angela davis told the
left forum last night for deep thinking
and analysis feminist analysis she said
in fact of the interlinkages of our
issues among those
we live in a nation that locks seven
million of us behind bars
that's engaged in its longest most
costly war on terror
even as 46 million face the terror of
hunger and poverty at home
a terror that forces many to sign up to
serve in that no same wars
we live in a nation where the richest
0.1
those with 20 million dollars or more
have doubled their share of our nation's
wealth since the 1960s
under our system of rigged prices
monopoly capitalism and financialization
of every bit of us down to our very
homes
that wealth of the top 1 thousandth
compounds
as does the poverty
and the two parties of property
with their police
and their borders
and their drones
and their detention camps
keep it that way
and our money media calls it a democracy
these are the times the tri-men's souls
wrote thomas paine in 1776 speaking of
life under british rule
in this special luncheon feature three
men accustomed to deep thinking
are going to apply themselves to the
legacy of pain
and consider the standards he identified
for rebellion
are they met as well today
in the corporate imperial age of the
koch brothers
as they were then under the hereditary
rule of george iii in the royal east
india company
angela davis called on us to consider
our history i've been asked just briefly
to sketch pains
in order to do that just briefly i'd say
that his common sense rights of man and
age of reason were the most widely read
political essays of the 18th century not
only in this country but in europe too
common sense published in 1776 is
credited with giving the war of
independence its rhetorical fire
and its vision of a non-hereditary state
with a constitution
he gave us the terms united states and
counter-revolution too
and he lived long enough to see and
participate in his way i would say in
both
he died in greenwich village in 1809
common sense the idea came with him from
the uk
where he was born in 1737 in a region
called east anglia his were rebellious
times where the echoes of the levelers
and the diggers hung in the air common
people
who'd fought privatization in the
enclosure of land and found themselves
executed and incarcerated our mass
because they demanded their natural born
right to the commons
pain apprenticed as a corset maker a
profession that took off as women's
lives not just our wastes
were being shrunk from robust vital
things equal participants in life
to child rearers enclosed domestic
objects
at least women of a certain class
in 1757 payne went to sea aboard the
king of prussia
as egalitarian-minded sailors and
pirates
protested impressment
forced labor forced service in the
military
payne stood up against impressment
in the rights of man
aboard ship as historian peter limbaugh
has taught us payne would have served
with people from all over the world
including africans irish and blacks from
the caribbean
he would have participated or at least
witnessed their grumbling and perhaps
their rebellions on board ship
he certainly was aware of their
rebellions against the british
throughout the 1700s
in which caribbean blacks africans irish
and even some of the colonized americans
too
but certainly the hetero-homo
multi-gendered
mob
the rowdies
carried with them the world the word of
slave revolts into the streets of what
were to become the united states
including new york's own streets
those slave revolts let's date them
jamaica 1760 bermuda and nevis 1761
suriname 62 63 68 and 72 british
honduras grenada monserrat saint vincent
tobago saint croix st thomas think kitts
throughout the 1760s and the 70s
there were rebellions
and they moved to the south alexandria
virginia in 1767 perth amboy new jersey
1772 saint andrews parish south carolina
and in a joint african and irish effort
in boston in 1774.
thomas payne arrived in america that
year and immediately wrote against
slavery
we have it in our powers to begin the
world over again he wrote in common
sense
20 years later
in agrarian justice
he acknowledged that even after
independence the world was in need of
serious remaking he wrote the present
state of civilization is as odious as it
is unjust
it is absolutely the opposite of what it
should be
and it is necessary that a revolution
should be made in it
the contrast of affluence and
wretchedness continually meeting and
offending the eye is like dead and
living bodies chained together
it wasn't just a us problem it was a
global problem he wrote the great mass
of the poor in all countries have become
a hereditary race and is next to
impossible for them to get out of that
state for themselves
for the sake of justice and humanity he
said not in 76 but in 1796
it is necessary to make change
specifically to make quote property
productive of national blessing
extending to every individual not just a
few
are we in times that try our souls
for sure let's hear it are
we are we in revolutionary times
that's the question we're going to
address today
and we'll recall angela davis who said
we should not be afraid to ask for what
we want
what robin kelly has called our freedom
dreams she said need not bear the
imprint of compromise
so
ask away
compromise not
to address all of this and more we have
richard wolff professor of economics
emeritus the university of massachusetts
amherst visiting professor at the new
school graduate program author of many
wonderful books including democracy at
work a cure for capitalism occupy the
economy challenging capitalism and
capitalism hits the fan the global
economic meltdown and what to do about
it he also hosts the wonderful weekly
economic update on wbai fm in new york
and syndicated nationally
chris hedges spent 20 years as a foreign
correspondent 15 of those for the new
york times where he was part of a team
that won a pulitzer prize
until he denounced the bush
administration's call to invade iraq and
lost his post at the times
he's the author of the bestsellers
empire of illusion war is a force that
gives us meaning and death of the
liberal class and he writes a weekly
column that you must read for the
website truthdig
cornell west has called himself a blues
man in the life of the mind long time
princeton professor
now at union theological seminary he's
best known for his classic race matters
democracy matters and his memoir brother
west living and loving out loud
he appears frequently on many programs
when they let him
as well as
on his dear brother tavis smiley's pbs
tv show he can be heard weekly with
tavis on smiley and west the national
public radio program distributed by
public radio international and i believe
also heard on wbai thank you all we will
um
the format
is going to be as follows uh wonderful
gina kim here has distributed cards if
you have questions you should write
those questions on a card we do not
absolutely do not guarantee to answer
all your questions
but we will um sort through discover
some themes and pose some questions to
the
speakers um once they've laid out their
argument for about 45 minutes i'll get a
chance to pose a couple of questions of
my own
and we'll have you out of here in 90
minutes or fewer enjoy
[Applause]
okay how's that okay
we selected payne for a couple reasons
uh first of all he's
uh arguably the only real revolutionary
theorist america has produced uh we've
produced some admirable anarchists
uh emma goldman and
alexander berkman
noam chomsky
dorothy day and others uh we have
produced
some
powerful
prophetic voices
out of oppressed communities
whether that is uh you know frederick
douglass or
uh malcolm x uh um
my friend cornell west and others um but
in terms of revolutionary theorists we
have uh almost none uh payne may be uh
the only one uh in many ways he was the
first uh intellectual in the sense that
he never tied himself to a political
party he was always in opposition to
power uh and i thought it opened the
discussion uh with rick and cornell
by
highlighting some of his major strengths
ones that i think we can learn from
the first would be that payne in a way
that many of the
four
figures of the revolution were not
understood the monarchy understood
british power he didn't come to the
united states until he was 37 and part
of his job in common sense was to
explain
the structures of power to the colonies
uh who didn't understand them even
figures like benjamin franklin
up until the very last moment wanted to
build a rapprochement with
the king
and payne it was part of payne's job
to explain why this wasn't possible and
i think one of the things that uh i
think all three of us probably feel and
i'll stop in a second and let you both
address this is
that uh there has been a misreading on
the part of the american left and even
among the progressive community of the
structures of power and for that reason
it has rendered us impotent we have
effectively been channeling our energy
back into a dead political system
i wrote uh many of nader's major
speeches for him in the 2008 election
and going back to 2008 there were a lot
of people at the left forum who had uh
drunk the kool-aid for barack obama and
i think that that was because they had
quite been diverted quite effectively
into the personal narrative of a
candidate which is irrelevant
in terms of understanding
the mechanisms of power and just as pain
understood that the imperial power of
the british uh
had essentially blinded itself that that
it's hubris uh made it incapable of
listening which is why you had one of
the largest armadas uh 350 ships sent on
new york uh
i think we are in a very similar moment
as well and uh maybe begin
cornell with you and
talk a little bit about the that
idea of structure of power
uh yeah
did you want to say something brother
wolf before i say something no okay
uh
i think it's for me it's not just a
question of that structural power it's
true that thomas paine
uh comes at 30 and 37 years old to the
new world and already has a critique of
not just good and bad kings but of
monarchy as a whole
so he's talking about a structural
systemic analysis that most of the
americans at the time had not moved
toward
that in 1776 there were over 400
pamphlets published the one pamphlet we
still read common sense so there's a
number of voices being lifted but here
this 37 year old who arrives lays bare
this critical structure of power but
keep in mind who he was
his father was a quaker
he he inherited
a fundamental
solidarity with the downtrodden with
those who were excluded
that he was willing always to cut
radically against the grain in his
conception of himself at 37 was
he was going to die
he was going to be willing to die
if he
ensuring that he would act honorably
think
critically
that he would be willing to sacrifice
his popularity for truth and justice and
would always fuse with other folk on the
ground in grassroots movements and so
even as he lays versus critical
structure of power he has a conception
of himself that is quaker-like i mean he
was not an atheist he was a deist he
hated organized religion he hated dogma
especially religious dogma but also
ideological dogma and viewed himself as
first and foremost
a member of those sly stone called
everyday people
he was a commoner to the core
and he engaged in a revolutionary act
and how he wrote not just what he wrote
because how he wrote was a critique of
the pomposity and the obscurity of the
lack of the latin
greek obsessed language of the edmund
burks and others that he was going to
speak a language that was so clear he
said i want to write as plain as the
alphabet for common folk because i come
out of the common folk so that was a
revolution in form and style and it was
the first time that folk who hardly
could read it all
could be read too
and get through
a language that was part of their
colloquial style
that was part of how they communicated
going back to the artisanal class he was
not working class he was an artisanal
class in in fedford village there in in
norfolk but he fundamentally identified
with the common folk what we don't have
today is we don't have intellectuals he
was the first american modern
intellectual unconnected
no doubt about that what we don't have
today intellectuals who have not been
seduced by the professional managerial
carriage
and the subculture of the university who
are fundamentally committed to the
plight and predicament of commoners
everyday people working people poor
people and view their calling not their
career as having organic connection with
their struggles no matter how strong or
no matter how weak they are now there
are some intellectuals that do that
fewer and fewer and fewer why because
what thomas paine didn't have to deal
with is the backdrop of impending
ecological catastrophe
the backdrop of possible nuclear
catastrophe
the fashionable character of being
cynical and despairing even as you are
highly professionally approved and
recognized
the sipping tea in the cafes
with a sharp analysis but no willingness
to pay a cost
no willingness to take a risk no
military no willingness to cut radically
against the grain
and of course he
dealt with the consequences you talked
to me he died right here in greenwich
village
72 years old
six people at his funeral two of them
black because that critique of african
slavery the first piece he wrote in
march of 1775 was real that led toward
the founding of the first
anti-abolitionist society in the new
world he was fundamentally committed to
a critique of white supremacy very rare
often times among highly visible
white intellectuals
brother chris is rare stanley around him
is rare rick wolf rare eric phone and
red we go
we can call the list because it is so
short
i'm not just talking about making a
symbolic gesture i'm talking about
fundamentally committed to your analysis
it's where white supremacy is an
integral integral factor among other
crucial factors and then you make the
organic connection that's the kind of
brother thomas payne was and it is very
very difficult to build on his legacy
even though we have to acknowledge just
how
crucial that challenge is
i want to pick up on something that you
all just did
when laura was still speaking before we
started
she asked how much change was needed or
some words that affect and it was a
strong
clear statement yes
then she asked about revolution
much less strong
much more wobbling
now tom paine is exactly about that
difference
just as the name of this conference
the name we chose for this conference is
reform and revolution
faced with a situation that's becoming
more and more
unequal unfair unjust and intolerable
what are we going to do
and what pain
for me
what makes him stand out
is the care
that he takes
to go right after that question
and the way i hear it
is this
we now face he says about his time
more than enough evidence decade upon
decade of accumulated outrages
injustices
attacks on our freedoms our rights and
our security
in a sense we've tried
to address this one and that one to work
out an accommodation here to get a
reform over there
we've been there
and we've done it
and it hasn't worked
and we got to face that
we can't make reforms most of the time
because the power structure arrayed
against us blocks us
but even worse
when occasionally we get a reform
that same power structure having lost
the effort to block it
now goes to work to undo it to reverse
it and to go right back to where they
were
therefore the conclusion pain reaches
and tries to teach the american people
then
is the same one i think many of us want
to teach now
you've got to change the system
not because it's an alternative to
achieving reforms
but because changing the system is the
only way
to make a reform that's durable
revolution is the way you complete the
reform process just as it's the
condition for the reforms you get to
last and to mean what you wanted them to
mean when you fought for them that's why
the word revolution rang in payne's work
so powerfully
it's a big change not this not that we
have to say to the king of england go
home
you're out of here
it's over
the british empire hundreds of years of
dominance
we quit we're go you're out of here
a powerful
ending of the colonial relationship that
gave this country its modern birth
it's whole history
an amazing thing to say to the people to
separate
and yet aren't we in the same
isn't that the legacy for us to
to finally say
and let me pick up on one theme here
because i know many of you have
encountered references to or if you
have a lot of time you've read the book
by thomas piketty
a lot of time is 600 pages it takes a
long time
and he's a good economist but as a
writer
not so much
uh
yes it's in our profession that's
absolutely normal um
the
but his point is the same isn't it
he says he studied capitalism for 250
years he and his colleagues says in in
california at berkeley are the go-to
statisticians to understand the
distribution of wealth and income in the
world these days
and his conclusion in that book capital
in the 21st century is that capitalism
inherently
anywhere and everywhere it has been
established produces as its inherent
tendency a growing inequality of wealth
and income
periodically he points out people get so
freaked by this that they push back and
we have a
reform and as soon as it's over the same
capitalism undoes the reform
and we all know that don't we here in
the united states because the last 40
years is the undoing of the new deal
there it is again
and so pain comes to us
and when chris said to me initially
let's start with thomas paine
now i see what was in his mind
he is teaching us
you got to have the courage
to make a systemic change
you've been to the reform
table you've tried it repeatedly
you have to learn the lesson we are at
the stage of taking a major new step
so of course we're a little nervous as
your hesitant comments to laura
indicated
but the logic
now is something we can understand
thanks to pains pushing through the way
chris and cornell just said
i think the the thing about pain that's
also very important and cornell alluded
to this is language
what the linguists call mutual knowledge
um and pinker has written stephen
pinker's written about this that uh
language is a vehicle by which reality
is filtered through to you
and part of pain's power which is the
power of all great revolutionary writers
is that he utterly upended that language
to the
extent that he redefined terms like
democracy democracy was a pejorative
republicanism or the republic was a
pejorative
and pain reclaimed those words and gave
them a new definition the other thing
which cornell also mentioned which is
important about pain is that he spoke in
the language or he wrote in the language
of
everyday people now um that
as a writer is deceptive um because it's
actually extremely difficult
um orwell mastered that capacity orwell
once said that you know i want as a
writer i want to be that clear window
pane by which people can see through and
payne did that uh and when he writes his
response to edmund burke
uh
in uh the rights of man he goes after
burke's very florid style
and i think language and i'll you know
want to raise this with both of you is
extremely important because we live in a
society now where those who have power
have created
specialized vocabularies that shut the
rest of us out economists have been
particularly good at this um but just
about the technocrat and we and we are
ruled by technocrats uh has created a
specialized vocabulary that those of us
on the outside are not able to penetrate
and that becomes a kind of barrier in
terms of our ability to exercise our
rights as citizens to influence power
and pain understood that extremely well
and it's why
his writings were so effective he's an
incredible writer i mean common sense is
arguably one of the greatest essays in
english um
when he writes uh the rights of man
especially the second part and and it
becomes extremely important because in
that second part of the rights of man he
actually outlines the whole welfare
state
um and the pitt government goes nuts
william pitt
and they pass uh the two act law which
uh bans um just as we see in the wake of
the occupy movement bans large public
gatherings uh makes it a lot easier to
prosecute people for treason uh payne
himself is tried for sedition and has to
flee to france i mean has amazing life
he ends up as a one of two foreign
delegates in the national convention
stands up and opposes the regicide of
louis xvi the jacobins turn on him he
ends up in prison um uh but when he
writes the rights of man he gives to the
english working class and you have to
remember that the working class in
england at the time was in far worse
economic state
than the white working class in the
united states uh three out of four or
um
people in uh large metropolitan cities
in europe were either poppers or beggars
uh and and when the pitt government it
creates all sorts of uh
uh worker organizations that begin to
discuss political issues the pitt
government shuts it down and drives it
underground but i think and ep thompson
makes this point that one of the reasons
payne is actually better known in
england is because he gave them the
whole vocabulary to the to the kind of
working class radical labor movement and
i think that that's an extremely
important issue and i and i think that
this gets to rick's point is people's
reaction is that we are still in a
process of searching for the language by
which we can number one describe the
political and social and economic
reality that we are enduring and how to
respond
and i think at the center of that
revolution in form and style of thomas
paine
was a
genuine
anger
a righteous indignation
of the conditions of the people that he
was fundamentally
working alongside and struggling
alongside with remember the line 24a of
plato's apology
socrates
was the cause of my unpopularity parisia
is plain speech
unintimidated
speech frank
speech
speech that is unafraid it's the
language of the great victoria garven of
malcolm x it's the language of dorothy
day of rabbi abraham joshua heschel it
cuts through the jargon it cuts to
specialized language it gets at the pain
but doesn't remain there because it
articulates the vision so that there's
an alternative to that pain that is also
was lacking
and that's what thomas paine had
and part of the problem is when we when
we do have persons with those voices
what happens what thomas paine went to
jail in london he's pushed out he's 11
months in prison in paris luckily makes
it out when he comes back here he has a
critique of george washington he has a
critique of evangelical religion in the
midst of the first awakening and he is
completely pushed aside so oftentimes
poor persons who have these voices are
either in prison incarcerated lied on
character assassinated literally
assassinated or just pushed to the
margins and viewed as some isolated icon
that one worships rather than views them
as part of a movement
you see
movie abuja mall
oscar lopez rivera we go on and on and
on in this regard you see so the
challenge is how do we build on payne's
example but we're living in a much more
crypto-fascist state than he was
that's the lesson of brother mummy and
others those who raise their voices the
national surveillance state the national
security state is on you the spies are
operating folk on the inside your
friends who used to you thought you
could rely on no not at all they're
cowardly they're too conformist they're
too complacent who do you rely on then
that's what thomas paine was wrestling
with most of his life he dedicates one
of the texts to george washington right
next thing you know george won't get him
out of the clinker
in paris
he's living with james madison in paris
then the critique of george washington
is so devastating george washington is
the icon when he comes to the state they
won't touch thomas payne with a 10 vote
for 10 foot pole because his critique of
george washington is so unrelenting he
has pulled the cover on the demagogue
nobody talks about george
he chopped down the cherry tree
nobody talks about george he sacrificed
wait a minute let's tell a story
that's honest and candid about george
washington especially for someone like
thomas paine who whose view is not just
black people
but thomas paine in the eastern plan in
pennsylvania when he met with indigenous
brothers and sisters and went on to
write what they were wiser than the
white folk they were talking to these
were my brothers and sisters these
indigenous peoples that's a vanilla
brother named thomas payne talking that
way
we don't even have white activists these
days enough talking that way with
indigenous peoples and brown peoples and
black peoples and asian people yeah we
got some in this room i'm talking about
as a movement
as a movement why because you grew up in
such compartmentalized deodorized spaces
where you had very little assets to
black folk and red folk and yellow folk
and others those vanilla suburbs and
went to these nice little elite schools
and got sophisticated
and so forth and not any way connected
to what these struggles have been thomas
paine refused that and he dropped he
left school when he was 12 and a half
now i'm not recommending that
but that's also a way in which he was
not incorporated so easily
by the gentleman of his day who never
accepted thomas paine
never except john adams jefferson even
when he said good things about him he
was still a commoner
he was still so unsophisticated and raw
and coarse you know the vicious lies
told about his personal hygiene and so
it may not be alive maybe he smelled a
little bit but
but i mean all the lies that were
unimportant relative to the issues that
he was talking about
that's how rare he was that's why it's
perfect to start with thomas paine
i think also
not to be the the good news bearer but
let's be clear
let's be clear
all the people who turned against him
along the way
the vast majority of them
we don't even know who they are
what survived was what this man wrote
and it didn't just survive because he
was a great writer he was and it didn't
just survive because he found ways of
changing the meaning of words that
brought people alive
incredible skills chris is right one of
the great writers
particularly the great writers of
revolutionary literature
the reason though he survives is that
it's the same question
and when you begin to look as christian
and then we did for what we could build
a lasting conversation around we found
him because he addresses
the same issue
what is to be done if i could borrow the
way another important leader posed the
question
uh what is to be done
this this
is his recognition and i think we ought
to be
for a moment proud that the united
states produced such a person
proud that we generated someone who
could pose the reform and revolution
question so dramatically that even
though his coming down on the side of
revolution
which frightens so many people
returns now
to something we want to talk about and
that we want you to
return to read and learn from as we have
because there's lots of very powerful
insight in there
about what it is we face now
and we do in this country face now
an extraordinary structure
that has done the things that were so
upsetting to to pain one example
that referred to by both of us all of us
democracy in those days was a word that
can akin to
chaotic
disorganized
messy
ineffective negative negative negative
right we live in a sense in a bizarre
reversal now it's the holy of holies
but it's all a fake
we celebrated democracy
the way we celebrate cowboys
in the old days
a complete fantasy
a makeup
so that we can indulge this desire
as an economist i keep saying this and i
know some of you've heard it from me
before
we go to work
we spend five out of seven days a week
at our jobs and when we go to work which
is where we spend most of our adult life
we enter a place in a capitalist society
that is the absolute opposite of
democracy a tiny group of people major
shareholders and boards of directors 25
30 people make all the decisions that
thousands of employees not to speak of
the communities where these employees
work have to live with
their participation in those decisions
is completely excluded
in principle in law and in fact
so we spend most of our adult lives in
an institution that is fundamentally
undemocratic
and pretend we live in a society with a
fundamental commitment to democracy
this is crazy
but it's a craziness that has to be
opened up
by the genius kind of vision that a pain
brings to it so that you kind of shock
a population into recognizing that all
along that's what's been bothering me it
isn't just that i'm poor it isn't just
that i'm living in a polluted
environment in an overcrowded city it's
that i'm not treated like a human being
and this is
this is revolutionary stuff
that moment of recognition if you can
help it along with the kind of writing
he had
that lights the fire it's very very
powerful
i want to talk about the two weapons
that were used against pain most
effectively the first was vilification
and when you stand up and speak a truth
as powerfully and eloquently as payne
does
the state uh and this was true both in
colonial america and especially true
in uh
the england of william pitt
and even finally in
the jacobin uh revolutionary france
where they were terrified of payne's
writing which is why he ends up in the
luxembourg and he doesn't just end up in
the luxembourg he's slated for execution
and the only reason he's not executed is
because they would mark the doors of the
people to be guillotined the next
morning and his door the door to his
cell was open
and they marked the inside of the door
and at night the guard closed it and he
sat in the room
holding his breath
waiting as the guards passed to pull
those people out of the luxembourg who
would be guillotined and they passed him
by that's the only reason payne is alive
and there's actually an amazing scene
where danton who had uh been an ally of
pain is brought to the luxembourg and
they embrace uh before danton is
executed um
so vilification
uh
there he was followed uh the government
of as they do here funded all sorts of
front organizations letter writing
campaigns uh and they destroyed him
uh that the power of vilification should
not be
uh
diminished it works
uh and pain was being burned in effigy
uh by the very people that he was
writing
for
uh in france of course he almost dies
because he opposes the reign of terror
he was a quaker in that sense he wasn't
a good quaker they wouldn't let him be
buried finally in a quaker burial but he
opposed the death penalty
including the regicide of the king and
he stood up in the national convention
and gave a quite an eloquent and moving
speech as to why even your enemy you
must even protect your enemies because
once you begin this kind of reign of
terror against those you oppose it comes
back to haunt you i mean very prescient
as to the direction of the french
revolution that's the first thing and i
know uh that
cornell west for speaking the truth
about the administration of barack obama
has suffered from this kind of
vilification
but it's a perfect example of what a
truth teller has to undergo the second
is historical amnesia
[Applause]
and
let's think about it
thomas paine was one of the most
important founders
of our country
where are the monuments to thomas paine
where
he he's been erased
as a kind of visible figure
and and this gets into the in
frightening kind of erasure of the
entire radical tradition
which has been extremely effective in
the united states and in a sense uh it's
a way of in a kind of stalinist way of
rewriting our own history i mean the
communist party
in this country and if you were a a
black person in the 1920s were you where
were you going to it's why robeson
joined the party because it was
integrated or ruskin and all the tactics
the king used came out of communist
tactics that were being used in the 20s
and the 30s
um the wobblies i mean i have to tell
this room you're aware of it but pain
represents that radical tradition that
the establishment has worked from the
beginning of the public to
erase
so that um pain even in his own lifetime
as cornell correctly pointed out becomes
a pariah i mean even jefferson who had
been a friend of pain
uh pushes him
away
and i thought maybe we could talk a
little bit about the mechanism the state
uses vilification and historical amnesia
in order to blunt and destroy the
radical prophetic voice yeah and that's
so very important to philadelphia 100
years
100 year anniversary of pain they took a
vote that refused to have a statue
anywhere in the city in tribute to him
that's philadelphia that's where he
struggled he walked on foot from trenton
to philadelphia in support of the u.s
military working with the military under
nathanael greene and george washington
american revolutionary war and that's
the kind of gratitude why because
why because he was so genuinely
revolutionary that once the revolution
was over in the united states we got to
move toward the counter-revolutionary
status quo
as the federalists set in
as their fear of the french revolution
set in the john adams and others but i
do want to add this probably the
greatest black revolutionary socialist
in the early part of the 20th century
was a brother named herbert harrison
he was the founder of local five
socialist party
he was the most popular lecturer in this
in the city of new york and was very
close to ingersoll as well as clarence
darrow
and it was reading thomas paine that
turned him into not simply a
revolutionary but also an agnostic now
payne was not an agnostic he was a deist
but when hubert harrison
he was a genius he's a caribbean genius
he came off the boat came straight to
harlem lived 134th street
and when he died
there was just seven folk there and it's
an unmarked grave to this day read
jeffrey perry's magnificent magisterial
biography and that's just volume one
you see
hubert harrison historical amnesia
everybody knows about booker t
washington
god bless the negro
he founded the black institution unfor
founding black institution all white
money on white elite money against the
unions against our precious immigrants
coming in deeply pro-capitalist
everybody knows booker t washington what
about hubert harrison in the legacy of
tom payne across race we could go on
that's why victoria garvin another
powerful magnificent voice who knows
about the great victoria garvin we need
to know more historical amnesia again
but when
times reach a point where the truth has
to emerge we're going to be so hungry
for these voices
because we want to be needful
of their insight but most importantly of
their courageous example
of their courageous example because at
that point you either courageous or you
go under
we're not at that point now that's why i
think one of the reasons why the folk
were a little reluctant when she said
revolutionary times
you see i i don't think we live in
revolutionary times i wish it were
revolutionary times pain arrived at a
moment where the revolution's already in
place
he just drops in
i wish we could just drop in
and have black folk
and white and red and yellow already
organized already anti-imperialist
already anti-homophobic already
anti-capitalist already anti
against jewish hatred and arab hatred a
hatred of muslims and so forth we can
just drop in on that and then write a
pamphlet
hey
[Music]
we gonna get together tonight and write
that
pamphlet we work all night right that
pamphlet no no these are
counter-revolutionary times where
there's revolutionary awareness
escalating given the defeat the relative
defeat of the left in the last 35 or 40
years with the counter-revolution
triumphing in the name of capital
in white supremacist garb even when you
have black figures who are the public
faces of it
you see that's what our moment it seems
to me and i think that's one of the
reasons why folk were a little bit leery
about that and i've resonated with that
leeriness because we do want to be
honest what we're up against
he said none of us gonna live through
the revolution we talking about at all
and some of us get crushed like
cockroaches
because the powers that be are powerful
they're mighty but not they're not
almighty pain believed that the people
organized or always mightier than the
gangsters who run things
but the gangsters are powerful
very powerful indeed there's no doubt
about that and vilification
well yeah but i mean i wouldn't compare
my case to thomas paine yeah good god
almighty yeah low low no but i mean i i
just think that the
uh uh it's it's impossible to tell the
truth
especially about the vicious legacy of
white supremacy and his connection to
capitalist exploitation without knowing
you're a candidate for character and
literal assassination that's just a fact
over 400 years there has never been
a person from john brown on the vanilla
side to nat turner to ella baker
who was told the truth about white
supremacy and his connection to
capitalism who was not targeted
chronically systematically across the
board
and that's why you have to have your
spirit intact you can you can get it
intact in a secular way i get it intact
with loving jesus people say whatever
they want that's you i got my mother hug
in life to live
i got my integrity to preserve
and how do you bear witness in the face
of those kinds of lives and those kinds
of crimes and that's what they are
they're crimes against humanity the new
jim crow is a crime against humanity
the educational systems in our cities
those are crimes against humanity the
way those precious children are treated
you see
a working class abused in this well
that's a crime against humanity
and the drones dropping bombs on
innocent children vicious crimes against
humanity in the name of the u.s people
you have to just call it for what it is
but using that kind of language doesn't
just get you in trouble
but it can get you killed yes
one last thought about this
and maybe there's a productive tension
between brother
cornell and myself
we don't know where we are in the
revolutionary process
you only know that afterwards
was it the right time
was it possible were the conditions in
place
you never know and part of what it means
to be
a critic
in the spirit of tom payne
is that you always got to push
you've got to push to see
where
and how far it can go
we are here
and you are here
[Applause]
and this is probably the
biggest attendance that the that is the
whole three days here that the left
forum has ever enjoyed
these are very interesting
bits of information
i think we have to always be willing
both to be cautious and honest about
what we're up against absolutely right
but always with a little space left
for that unknowable
reality
when the things begin to happen really
quickly
that author i referred to earlier from
another place in time
who made famous that question
what is to be done
was famous for another remark he made
about this question
he said sometimes
for decades
nothing happens
and then in a few weeks
decades happen
we have to be open
thomas payne was open
because if you're not open you can't
write that way
part of the it's not just the effect his
writing has on the revolutionary
situation
it's also the fact that a revolutionary
situation even when not grasped
consciously
plays its role
in shaping what it was possible for
thomas paine to write and we have to be
in
in sync with that
unknowable
extra that's there
partly to live in a time like this and
partly to be able to be progressive in a
time like this
alexander berkman in an essay
writes about uh called the essays called
the invisible revolution precisely that
point where he talks about a life
in a revolutionary society as being like
a kettle that is boiling
and that you don't actually see anything
that all of the
uh traditional edifices of power and
structures not only remain in place but
appear monolithic
and that when they collapse when they go
down it's
it appears to be absolutely sudden
and unpredictable and like as a foreign
correspondent that was something that i
experienced covering the revolutions in
eastern europe uh including the east
german stasi state
where uh until our security and
surveillance state was the most
pervasive
uh
uh
security apparatus in human history
we've of course done things the stasi
didn't even dream of
and
and what happened was
you had
in leipzig
mostly lutherans
holding candlelit vigils and they
weren't even very clear about uh they
for the if their first demand was that
they'd be legally recognized as a group
they hardly appeared revolutionary and
yet they they captured that kind of
zeitgeist
which i think is there within the
american society looking for a language
to express itself and and and and pain
gave revolutionary america that language
um but i think in that sense we
we are rapidly losing faith
in
the institutions the formal structures
of power uh which have been
become wholly owned subsidiaries of the
corporate state
um but language is key and burkman makes
that point that as long as you can you
continue to speak in the false language
of american democracy liberty how can
you use the word liberty when every
single one of us in this room
has all of our electronic communications
downloaded and stored in perpetuity by
the nsa you cannot use the word liberty
for a population that has wholesale
surveillance
you have to use the word slavery
and
any government that has the capacity to
use
that mechanism
will use it hannah aaron writes in the
origins of totalitarianism that the the
purpose of wholesale surveillance in a
totalitarian state is not to find crimes
but to gather evidence so at the moment
that you seek to criminalize an entire
group of people you have
the trivia it's not evidence because of
course at that point crimes and truth
and all of this is is is a fiction but
you have the material and that's
precisely what's happening
to us
and so when that stasi state fell it
fell in a week and it fell when suddenly
this handful of protesters in leipzig
were joined by 70 000 people
and eric honaker who had been in power
for 19 years sent down an elite
paratroop division to fire on the crowd
and the paratroopers wouldn't do it
just in the same way the cossacks would
not fire during the bread riots and
petrograd which forced the czar to get
into a railway carriage and and abdicate
even before he got back to petrograd um
and so and the same thing happened in
uh in east germany hanukkah was gone was
gone within a week because those
paratroopers would not shoot on the
crowd so i have a question that's
completely related to what you just said
um because i think in so far as we're
talking about the anatomy of revolution
we also need to talk about the anatomy
of the counter revolution and how if
we are talking about a man who was an
abolitionist and who was the great
rhetorician of the revolution we end up
with a slave-holding republic how it was
that u.s
not colonial but u.s
forces did fire
on rebels
in the shae's rebellion and the
uprisings against debt
in that period between
the declaration of independence and the
writing of the constitution
thomas paine
supported the banks getting paid
he was against the mob he said you get
changed by rule of law or by the
military or by the mob and he was on the
side of the law
our laws come out of that period
um i'd love you to address the anatomy
of the counter revolution well the thing
to remember about payne was that in
pennsylvania
uh there was no divide between wig and
torrey uh the pennsylvania elite which
was quaker and anglican were wholly on
the side of the british monarchy
uh the pennsylvania assembly backed the
property class
and so unlike in the other colonies the
opposition
to the king and the independence
movement was expressed through pain
and radical constitutionalists who
had no connection
with pre-revolutionary power
and so that in pennsylvania after the
revolution those who take power
unlike every other colony
uh had not been in power before
now this alliance was extremely uneasy
because as you correctly point out with
a slave holding class and let's forget
not forget that
we had at the beginning of the
revolution
african-american soldiers
until george washington a slaveholder
banned the conscription of blacks into
the continental army
the only reason that the southern
slave holding class
supported the republic and they had
remembered they had had a rebellion of
landless whites the bacon rebellion in
the 17th century the only reason they
supported it was because the laboring
class
was
who were black and enslaved were pushed
out of the political system so you have
this kind of false
narrative or false language that's used
by figures like jefferson while ignoring
uh huge percentages so
once the revolution is over and they
knew this even before the revolution
they had to push pain out as fast as
they could because that abolitionist
egalitarian
uh movement
was
uh even at the time of the revolution of
an alliance of convenience but made them
very uncomfortable and on the issue of
the banks and i'll let rick deal with
this more
um
and i would just say that payne's
conception of laissez-faire capitalism
came out of adam smith
not malphus and and adam smith had a
very benign view i'm now about to
probably embarrassing myself immensely
but
my very meager understanding a
seminarian not an economist was anyway
that that that there was a kind of naive
view that laissez faire capitalism was
any you know created a kind of equality
and um i think pain was wrong wrong on
this justice i think pain was very uh
naive about human perfection and um as
cornell would say you know a misunder an
inability to understand sin um and human
corruption um so that when pain is in
support of the banks and against the
paper currency which did cause
hyperinflation um it comes out of this
naive belief that that that was a
democratizing force
well i mean one of pain has a developing
views about the economy it's very
different what it says in common sense
and what he says
in the rights of man and the last major
peace agreement justice agreeing justice
and that second volume of rights which
is basically social democratic he called
for the first person to call for
guaranteed minimum income right
guaranteed minimum income and the very
front page of his agrarian justices
every citizen ought to receive a
lump of money when they're 15 in order
to receive another major lump of money
when they're 45. from inheritance no
matter what inheritance you break down
the inheritance transmittance of wealth
at the top and people get a chance to
start their teenage years anew and then
right before the worms get you i'm 45
start that anew again with another
injection but so at least i mean so he's
he's very fragmented he's not systematic
and he's certainly not marks uh at all
but
in regard to the banks too i think
thomas paine
thomas paine did not receive one penny
from the money he got from common sense
or from the rights of man these are the
two
best-selling texts in the history of the
english language didn't give receive a
penny every penny just like martin king
the nobel prize every penny went to the
movement every penny went to the cause
when he called for the banks early on
that was a way of supporting providing
financial support for the war
and so they we had to have a national
entity that would provide some resources
that keep the war going in an
anti-imperial way but he supported them
after shays as well
but he supported them after shays as
well what but he did have a suspicion of
the mob the mob ought to deserve
suspicion the mob can be run by
gangsters too you have to be very
critical in this regard when he talked
about the people he wasn't
viewing it as an abstraction
he had a critical view toward whether
there was democratic sensibility and
vision when people talked about the
people now in shae's rebellion i would
argue he was still he was still wrong
i'm not defending him in terms of a
particular judgment but his larger
vision and sensibility something i wanna
i guess i raised the question because of
its relevance today as we try to decide
where our allies are and define the the
basic composition of the community of
the population that we're in um
because my other question to you has to
do with
this question of
the intellectual revolutionary today
because i think i disagree with you
cornell
um
somebody's right
but that's good
i mean on grit tv every week we're
interviewing grassroots intellectual
revolutionaries
i'm thinking of people like max ramo
from the right to the city i'm thinking
like peop of people like kaliyakuno who
worked with chokwe lumumba in jackson to
take power and to call for a total
transformation of the economic
priorities of that city in a place where
that was viable i'm thinking of the
dreamers
with no access to power with no access
to the system changing our entire
um the comfort of the congress around
their immigration policy even occupied
they got a lot of help from the media
but then they got a lot of hurt from the
media
um but they raised the question of
capitalism in a way that we could talk
about it in a way that we hadn't been
able to for years so
i'm yes my suspicion
of the mob
makes me uncomfortable because some of
my favorite people are in the mob um and
sometimes it's hard who's to tell who's
the mob and who's the mob capital m and
the mob capital m are in government
brother rick you want to drop your nose
because we don't want dominic but i'll
say something immediately after but you
go right ahead though all right um
let's be
generous to tom paine he thought
that many of the problems he saw
accumulating in this society
at the time of our colonial
link to britain
could be overcome by a cataclysmic act a
revolution
cutting us off
from this society of which we had been a
colony
rejecting the monarchy rejecting the
support
unbelievable
he then
had to face as many revolutionaries have
that what it was
he thought was the problem
turned out to be
only part of the problem it was a
necessary but not a sufficient step to
take to achieve the goals he so
brilliantly put forward for us
that he so brilliantly expressed
so we learn in the aftermath of thomas
paine either with him or after he dies
after him
that there's more to be done
that being an independent country cut
off from your colonial master is
necessary
but it's not sufficient
how many nations have been discovering
that in the last 200 years
particularly in the so-called third
world
it's necessary
but it's not sufficient what else has to
be done well what law referred to
we have to understand that if we
actually want to realize the goals of a
thomas paine
whether they're articulated in the
american idiom or in the liberty
equality fraternity idiom of the french
revolution
more has to be done
that's what inspired
if i may be so bold karl marx that's who
he is he's born in the euphoria of the
american and french revolutions
he's caught up in all of that he
believed in it he loved it it's just
when he looked around
germany in his time
it wasn't happening the way it was
supposed to
the end of the feudal regime hadn't
brought liberty and equality in
fraternity
it had brought capitalism which they
early thought might be the road to
liberty equality and fraternity and then
they made this crucial discovery
that capitalism isn't the bearer of
liberty equality and fraternity it's the
biggest obstacle imaginable
and then begins the learning that we're
part of
that the next revolution
inspired and even made possible by the
likes of tom payne
now have to be informed by what's our
problem and that isn't
a king
that's a piece of theatrics in a few
leftover countries who have to have
kings and queens
and we feel empathy for the money they
piss away on that
our problem is an economic system
but it's not that pain was wrong he
needed to open the space so we could get
to what's on the agenda
for the human race now and that's an
enormous debt we have to him all right
so some other questions coming from the
uh uh from the audience lyndon famously
remarked in his article backward europe
advanced asia that the center of
anti-capitalist revolutionary had
revolution had switched to the third
world in the era of monopoly capital do
you agree
i don't think you can talk about the
third world as monolithic it depends on
which corner of the world we're talking
about
i don't think it can be broadly
characterized in in that way
in the same way that i i agree with you
and the examples that you gave you see
folks who are
telling the truth exposing lives bearing
witness in the name of the struggles
upon working people are not a mob
that's not the mob see it only becomes a
mob when the gangsters take over just
like the reign of terror the french
revolution that's when the mob spilled
over into gangster activity in the name
of the people
just like they were gangsters in the
name of the king
there's gangsters in the name of the
church gangster the name of the
synagogue drinks the name of judaism
against the name of christianity gang's
in the name of
buddhism or
whatever for thomas paine this is where
for take for him actually this was what
he called a religious duty he thought as
a deist he's following the will of god
by doing justly loving mercy
loving mercy and endeavoring to make his
fellow creatures happy that's the
language from
the rights of man but in the essence of
the question is has the center of
revolution shifted away from here to
someplace else
it was never in american empire says
when is american empire been the center
of revolution other than 1776 and
possibilities in 1960
america has been the bastion
of white supremacy and the rule of
capital ever since 1776 is that right
brother wolf
people we've had we've had resistance
and protests more questions but we
haven't had a south africa we haven't
had a venezuela we haven't had a cuba we
haven't had a china we haven't had i
mean
india in 1948 america has been the
bastion of capital of of of of what
would lenin call the dictatorship of the
bourgeoisie and and that's why violence
in america is vigilante violence
uh we are the you know what is it 80 80
out of every 100 americans owns a weapon
and the government has nothing to fear
because trade and this is the problem
that that the
the one sort of figure in our
revolutionary intellectual tradition
pain which has been who has been
marginalized in silence uh
has not had any heirs
and and so and hofstetter writes about
this in that book on violence quite
presciently
that uh you know you go back and look at
american history whether it's the slave
patrols or the pinkertons or baldwin
felts or you know the the coal mining
gun thugs or
uh you know the vigilantes who shot down
the miners at blair mountain that or you
know right up to the tea party the
militias that violence in american
society
uh
doesn't revolve around in a way that it
did in europe around a transformative
ideology
uh but around these kind of
proto-fascist
hatreds
and that and that is something that as
we move forward as a nation
and and and we endure the effects of
climate change and economic
disintegration we are going to have to
confront
you know look at nevada
suppose those people had been from earth
first or suppose they'd been black what
do you think would have happened
and and in a way
those vigilantes become
important to the system tolerated
occasionally reprimanded but tolerated
because in a moment of crisis
they become used by the capitalist state
so you have the klu klux klan in the
1920s
three to five million members
reign of terror in the south taking over
whole states including indiana
and and that is something we are going
to have to confront these uh you know
these armed militia figures these
survivalist cults and adam lanza's
mother was a member these which have
terrorized african americans throughout
their history
uh and and and been used to kill
radicals in ludlow those people were
killed by vigilantes um that i think is
an example of how
uh
the the rage a legitimate rage and anger
has been very skillfully manipulated
to turn on the vulnerable on the
scapegoats on the week and let me just
in terms of revolutionary tradition we
should not forget that we are
the british monarchy right we are the
empire
and we have the disease of empire so
that even i don't talk to very many
people in princeton except for cornell
because even at princeton university you
will get these absurd discussions about
sending 101st airborne to afghanistan to
liberate women
as if you can talk about and i've been
to war and they haven't as if you can
talk about human rights once you start
using cruz and hellfire missiles so i
think the answer to the question was
don't worry about the center of
revolution shifting someplace else
because it was never here
um
it doesn't mean you don't struggle here
one more question
because this topic has come up a lot in
your questions um and this is can you
connect payne's radicalism to the
immediate crises associated with climate
change
there's a couple of questions related to
climate change
does climate change give us an
opportunity galvanize a revolutionary
segment of society or will business
continue as usual until it's too late
and if we had a source of abundant
energy would we have a revolution well
here
i'll let rick and cornell address this
as well but here i would break with pain
pain not only believed in like the
enlightenment human perfectibility
but he also believed in
uh wholeheartedly in
material advancement and material
progress he said the earth that's given
to us is our inheritance
and he broke with jefferson on this i
mean jefferson was terrified of the
industrial revolution and wanted to sort
of slow its effect payne saw it as a
benefit and and you know payne often
talked about uh uh giving up political
activity and he designed an iron bridge
and he had like many of the artisan
class of the day a deep interest in
science so uh i think you know if we
talk about blind spots in pain that
would probably be
a one yeah
well i i think the the way i would
connect pain to the the whole climate
thing is it's sort of
we are now forced to see
yet another
consequence of capitalism and the way
its intrinsic logic
endangers us that is it's not just as
piketty shows us that it produces absurd
social inequalities that are
self-destructive but it also
distorts our relationship to the to the
ecosphere and that it's another argument
but it doesn't then just takes us back
to having to confront we have an
economic system that is fundamentally
dysfunctional for the vast majority of
us
what are we going to do
about this situation
and no matter how alarmist your reaction
to the environmental it really is
another kind of alarmism that you can
likewise generate for social inequality
and for many of the other consequences
of capitalism that always bring you back
to
are we able now to think through a
relationship to capitalism that's
parallel or comparable to what pain took
us through in thinking our relationship
to a colonial master
and that means the oligarchs and the
plutocrats of our day wall street big
banks and big corporations
are the equivalent of the monarchs in
history that's right
it means that poverty is a new slavery
it means that the new jim crow is an
intense form
of slavery it means that working people
locked into
a declining
economy in which wages stagnate
prices escalate and profits go hit the
top is also a form of slavery
metaphorically and literally speaking
and we need
language like that to somehow seize the
imagination of people to begin to see lo
and behold there's either a way out or
there's not now climate change for me is
a very serious issue i don't think it's
going to be the catalytic issue
i think it's either going to be
revolutionary transformation that allows
us to get some control over banks and
corporations so we can treat nature as a
vow rather than an it
but when i hear a lot of this goes to
climate change i hear people thinking oh
my god my life is going to be like a
wasteland well you know for poor people
it's a wasteland every day
every day
every year
year after year
year after year but how do we make the
connection between the climate change
agents on the one hand but also those
who are wrestling with these new forms
of slavery in the neo-liberal capitalist
regimes around the world and to recoup
one little piece of credit for the
united states
thomas paine
teaches us to think about revolution as
a matter of changing a system
that's a very powerful contribution it
made him stand out from others at his
time and it's urgently necessary for
more of us nowadays to be willing and
able to confront not this or that
outrage not this or that intrusion on
our lives but a system
that supports and reinforces all of that
and will outwit us as long as we don't
confront it as a system and that we need
thomas payne's help to do
well on the system's point
it's worth remembering that the tea
party after all was not against the king
so much as against the company the east
india company and the mur the
relationship between the royal power the
monarchy and the corporation something
very familiar today
looking at all of this a couple of
people wanted to ask your exact
suggestions we have your suggestions for
how to keep hope your suggestions for
how to start a organized movement
and your suggestion
for things people can mobilize around
today and i'm com condensing a few
different questions but insofar as pain
put forward concrete suggestions whether
it was around the con the continental
congress or around the um
inheritance tax and the guaranteed
minimum income what would yours be today
are there things like that that one
could organize or you would like to see
us organizing around
and we've got about four minutes
i'll give you five
well let me start
while my colleagues figure out what
they're going to say
i have
one thing that i get out of thomas paine
although i get it from other places too
that i think
begins to confront the systemic issue
we depend as human beings on the
enterprises in our society that produce
the goods and services without which
life cannot continue our food our
clothing our shelter our transportation
and everything else
we permit the institutions that we
depend on the productive institutions to
be organized in a fundamentally
undemocratic way that leave all the
decisions those that affect the
environment those that affect the
distribution of wealth those that affect
everyday life in the hands of a tiny
number of people that sit atop the
pyramid of these institutions what we
call corporations
if we don't want this set of outcomes we
call the consequences of capitalism then
we have to fundamentally alter the
organization of production if we want
the production of goods and services the
core economic base of our lives to serve
all of us then we have to be in charge
of them and it can't be a subset of us
that arrogates that position to itself
the radical transformation what chokwe
lubumba was beginning to do and talk
about in jackson mississippi is part of
a
broadening recognition that that
fundamental revolution that reorganizes
production
is where we have to go to
achieve to concretize where pain's work
pushes us
anyone else yeah just very belief i'm
thoroughly convinced that if 40 of
america's children lived in poverty and
one out of three of america's children
of young people were on parole in prison
or probation
it'd be a very different historical
moment if 40 of white children lived in
poverty and one out of three of white
young brothers between 18 and 26 were on
parole probation or in prison we'd have
a different moment it'd be maybe a
revolutionary moment which means that
we're going to say do something about
the vicious legacy of white supremacy
and it's relation to
the neo-liberal capitalist regime that
is so tied to lies and crimes so the
issue of black and brown and folk is not
just a moral issue of being morally
sensitive
it is an anti-systemic
issue that goes right back to what
brother wolf is talking about and that's
precisely the reason why
black
young people are disproportionately
targeted because the only time we've had
the possibility of that was in the 1960s
and they came at it so viciously
that's why we still got the political
prisoners and the warriors that are
there they came at us viciously and
they're ready to come back viciously
again the difference will be this time
it will be blackface
that will also lead the vicious attack
the carl rowans and the others who lied
on malcolm lied on martin they they were
not in positions of power now you've got
black elites at the very top of the
empire who can facilitate the vicious
attacks that's why sante shakur is on
the top 10 list being a terrorist with a
black president in the white house and
she's a black freedom fighter
and we don't want to say a word about it
shame on us
in terms of the legacy of what folk went
through just 30 or 40 years ago in these
kind of settings where they told the
truth and look what they had to go
through and we so easily turn our backs
and say lo and behold their service
their sacrifice can be marginalized in
the same way that our dear brother
thomas paine one last point footnote
there's only one figure that's
comparable to thomas paine david walker
appeal to colored citizens of the world
and david walker did what wrote his text
and died in that hotel room 11 months
after after the spies got to him but he
went with a smile the way thomas paine
went with a smile because he told the
truth and he exposed lies and he bore
witness chris you got a minute uh i
would say that the reason we are in such
an incendiary moment as that the
political and economic
cultural oppression of poor people of
color is now being visited on the sons
and daughters of the white middle class
and that is basically the engine of the
occupy movement these are day class a
intellectuals bakunin always cited these
day class a intellectuals as vital for
revolution arguing with marks on this
but bakunin was right
so suddenly you have the sons and
daughters white
who endure police oppression who can't
get a job or at least a job where they
can sustain themselves who are enduring
what poor people marginalized people of
color have been endured for decades and
at that moment the state is in serious
serious trouble because an alliance
between an alienated
white essentially middle class or
formerly middle class our middle class
is disappearing of course
those people of color especially low
wage working poor uh is one that i think
once is galvanized can begin to create
and that's why the fight for the minimum
wage is absolutely crucial debt peonage
is a form of political control it's put
on there on purpose ask any
african-american it's how sharecroppers
were kept in slavery long after slavery
was officially abolished
and what we have done to college
students in this country is absolutely
criminal i mean my son is in france i
said if you told french college students
that they'd have to pay fifty thousand
dollars a year to go to college they'd
shut the damn country down which is
precisely what you should be doing here
all right um
hello everybody
so i will just close by say
something's coming it's always it's
always the ruling elites that determine
the configurations of rebellion they are
unable to respond rationally to the
mortgage foreclosure crisis to the job
crisis to climate change they know
they have no internal limits they will
exploit until exhaustion or collapse and
there will be blowback
i want to just thank our participants
cornell west chris hedges rick wolf talk
to your neighbors before they join the
vigilantes and make revolution everybody
thank you
[Applause]
i just want to thank our friend here
victor madison from the thomas payne
friends who's been
brought these in beautiful
posters to give to each of us